>> Weininger:
Hi, I'm Nick Weininger,
and I'm an engineer
on Google Custom Search Engine.
And at Google I/O,
I'm going to be giving a talk
on advanced
custom search configuration.
You may have already heard
about a custom search engine
as a tool for allowing you,
very easily
through a web interface,
to create a search engine
that is built on Google
search results,
but searches over a slice
of the web you're interested in,
which can be one site
or some parts of a site,
or a thousand
different sites.
But what you may not know
is that Custom Search
is also a very powerful
developer platform,
and that's
what I'm going to talk about.
The reason that it is
a developer platform
is that we provide an XML API
both for the definition
of our custom search engine
and for the results
that you get back
when you query
a custom search engine.
And using that XML API,
you can programmatically create
large numbers
of custom search engines.
You can use the API to provide
advanced ranking tweaks
so that the ranking of your
search results is different
from that of regular
Google search results,
and you can customize
the presentation
of your results,
so that they look
very different
from Google search results
and can be mashed up
with other content
that you have.
To give you briefly an example
of how that XML API works,
let me show you
what a custom search engine
definition looks like.
This is, in some sense,
the top level part.
It gives you the title
of the custom search engine.
It gives you some labels
which pertain to the refinements
that you can have
to navigate in that engine,
including one as you see
which is "BOOST" labeled,
which tweaks the ranking.
And then it points
to these other labels
which we'll use in another part
of the XML definition
to define the set of sites
that's included
in the custom search engine.
So if you want to hear more,
if you want to know more
about how to configure
custom search engines
for your users,
please come
to my Google I/O talk--
Advanced Custom Search
Configuration.
Thank you.